Resuelve "P" igual a "2l" más "2w" para "l".
Esta que tenemos aquí es la fórmula para
el perímetro de un rectángulo.
El perímetro es igual a dos veces el largo
más dos veces el ancho, lo que nos están
pidiendo es que resolvamos esa ecuación para "l".
Entonces tenemos que "P" es igual a "2l" más
"2w", necesitamos despejar "l", para eso dejaremos
este término que contiene "l" del lado derecho
y los demás términos los voy a pasar del
lado izquierdo, para lograr esto restemos
"2w" vamos a restar "2w" del lado derecho
y para que no se altere la igualdad, necesitamos
también restar "2w" del lado izquierdo.
Del lado izquierdo resulta "P" menos "2w"...
"P" menos "2w" lo cual es igual...
¿del lado derecho qué nos resulta?
Estos dos términos "2w" menos "2w" se cancelan
y nos queda tan solo "2l" y ahora para despejar
"l" necesitamos dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre 2, dividimos entre 2 el lado
izquierdo y entre 2 el lado derecho, el lado
derecho nos queda 2 sobre 2 se cancelan
y hemos despejado la "l" que es igual a "P"
menos "2w" sobre 2 ó si queremos escribirlo
de la manera usual, "l" es igual a "P"
menos "2w" sobre 2.
Y así hemos concluido.